leur bus les a déposés aux alentours de
14 heures au gymnase alain mimoun de
villepreux ce mardi 3 décembre 91
réfugiés tibétains sont arrivés dans la
commune en provenance d'un campement de
fortune situé à achères un site évacué
par la préfecture un peu plus tôt dans
la matinée
maintenant je me sens mieux parce que
nous n'avions pas de maison la nuit
faisait vraiment très froid
on est très très très content on est
très satisfait on remercie vraiment
toutes les personnes qui ont contribué à
la victoire en fait parce que c'est une
victoire quand même pour nous à leur
arrivée les réfugiés ont été accueillis
avec un thé chaud et des biscuits par
une vingtaine d'habitants de la commune
venus bénévolement un élan de solidarité
qui a commencé via un service de
messagerie instantanée dimanche dernier
beaucoup de villes provient se sont
mobilisés actuellement on est à peu près
70 qui ont souhaité donc venir en aide
sur la logistique les repas la
convivialité éventuellement les inviter
chez nous de temps en temps pendant la
durée de leur séjour dans la commune
certaines activités associatives de la
ville ont dû être déplacés sur d'autres
sites
la première des choses c'est qu'en tant
que maire on a une crainte très égoïste
on se dit mais comment je vais faire
pour que la ville continue de
fonctionner il ya une très forte
collaboration de l'ensemble des
associations qui étaient impactés tout
simplement pour se mettre en phase qui
va aller ou pas ce que c'est vrai qu'on
perd quand même une salle majeur donc il
fallait qu'on replace les associations
dans la ville les réfugiés devrait
rester jusqu'au 5 janvier dans la
commune i mme seront de nouveaux
déplacés dans une autre ville après
cette date